hello everybody hope that you're good
and today I really mean it because $2
billion doar have been liquidated uh
today well in the last 24 hours and
that's a record that's uh the biggest
loss in the history of the crypto market
so yeah I really hope that you guys are
safe and I'm very happy to read some
messages that my content has been
helping you and especially yesterday in
the Bitcoin soon the update that I was
talking
when we were at 97k 98k we were talking
about the drop to 91k the Bitcoin was
very Bish and it was simply because what
we were saying in the last video that I
posted here on YouTube so if you want go
and watch it now uh so you can see well
it's not hand side you can learn from it
and basically what we're saying is that
there is something called the wick fill
strategy that is very strong and it
means that 6% of weeks at least that's
what I back tested 96% of weeks get
filed at some point soon or later and we
had a few weeks you know you have this
one here you also have this one here and
of course this one that is the largest
one are the range lows and I was saying
in during the video that I was not
paying attention at the lower weeks and
I didn't even mention them in the past
because I could see momentum to the
upside but once we form this wi to the
upside at the range highs then to me it
was pretty clear that we want to do
something like this you know go up to
the range highs uh retest the range
highs basically fill at least the 50% of
this week to the upside then drop to the
range well to the mid range sorry where
we would be feeling this second week at
that level we could see a shter bounds
that's what happened there I expected it
to be honest a lot more shallow and then
what would happen after would be drop
lose the midrange on The Daily 15a this
is what I posted the Bitcoin soon the
update that's why I was very Bish
yesterday around uh 12 hours ago and I
was calling for this for the range lows
this third week to the downside getting
F all right and that's what has happened
so um again if I've been able to help
somebody with this
uh to save a bit their portfolio perfect
I know that in Futures uh we go saved
obviously in a spot is been am messed
all I mean we're want to go through all
the charts now but everything has pretty
much dumped really hard so um if you
know if your portfolio is negative uh
it's it's completely normal and this
drops happen in in every single bull
market it doesn't mean that the bull
market is over we're want to go through
different
High time frame asaros 2 but for now I
would say stay calmed because it's
pretty normal and if we if you've been
here for long enough for I would say 3 4
years you've seen things like this and
then usually they Mark bottoms for
example the K crash the FTX crash the
Luna crash so uh let's see how it go so
far what is still with the in within
this structure this range you can see
that we has retested the range lower
support so so far that's fine now if we
talk about weeks many of you are
wondering if this new week that we are
creating today if it if it's valid for
the week F strategy and I mean the guys
many guys in the replies they're telling
you no um and that's a correct answer
those guys have probably done the course
um simply because a week that has been
created to fill a previous week
doesn't need to get filled it's as
simple as that that week has this week
here of today's week has been
created only to fill this inefficiency
here okay this other week so this one
here is not valid it and now again it
doesn't mean that price cannot do
something like this of course it can but
if it does go back to the range lows and
F this new week it's not because of the
week it's not because of it
okay so um that's something that I
wanted to to mention um to make clear um
now the next thing is that um in the
high time frame okay this is the high
time frame there is something that I
would like to see at some point and is
the weekly 50ma getting retested again
now that label is around 90 well
75k and you can see that it's pretty low
but of course it's a dynamic Target it
keeps
rising and again what in this structure
yes I can see Wicks to the upside but
realistically I can see even more weeks
to the downside that means that you know
there is some kind of uh desire to hold
price in within this range for for some
time right so I would wait here for a
breakout or a breakdown from this range
and so far what I would keep doing is
you know what I've what we've been doing
for the past few months and is you know
trading these range that means that at
the range lows we'll be looking for
Longs and at the range highs we'll be
looking for shorts so nothing really has
changed in Bitcoin really you know in
the weekly time frame is only a 2.60%
drop it's nothing all right now what
matters is that of course if you go to
ethereum you know and the rest of the
crypto Market it it changes a lot for
example in
ethereum we've seen this week uh 9% drop
last week was 11% drop so in total you
know that's a considerable drop and to
me what matters here the most is a
couple of things the first thing is that
if you notice this white line here that
used to be this range highs is being
retested again as support you can see
there so if anybody had any py limit
orders at the level not my case and I
reget that that's
fantastic now if you notice we have a
very long week and this long week is not
filling a previous one is it no it's not
so therefore this new week it's likely
to get filled okay that means that if
you guys have missed the bottom well if
you think you've missed the bottom it's
not it's not it's not it wouldn't be
correct to say that because 96% chances
the price revisits at least the 50%
level of that week okay that would be
around
2,366 but
again the daily candle hasn't been
closed yet it still has a few more hours
well a lot more hours so let's see how
that closes but if he would close as
it's right now then you could expect
price to go back at least to the 50% and
then potentially form a bottom okay and
prices would recover
because I tell you again when there is a
liquidation Cascade like we've seen
yesterday usually that marks at least
potential bounce and opportunities in
the short term so um what I be what I'm
looking here basically is you know I'm
seeing Bitcoin quite stable even if you
don't think so look at this structure
again isn't within the range at the
range lows retested a support and to me
is quite stable at the moment okay so
based on that then I can consider the
idea of trying some Longs for recoveries
you know in ethereum so if I see
something like this you know I'll be
looking to Long here I'll be looking to
Long here and I'll be looking to get out
if we find acceptance back inside this
range okay go back to the weekly time
frame if we do something like this then
you know that is the signal to get out
of the your lungs because it's likely
that we go back all the way down to the
range lows okay and that would be huge B
um so far that's what the chart is
telling me now I've been right about
Bitcoin but I've been wrong for example
about ethereum and Bitcoin pair I
thought that that Z line was going to be
able to hold because I had the line
marked for many months and I could see
you know some kind of a potential bottom
formation here uh not the case
completely ripped to the downside so uh
gr on the idea and that is basically why
ethereum in the dollar pair has dropped
so much because you know if
ethereum is H
underperforming and and doing so bad in
the Bitcoin pair then imagine if Bitcoin
drops ethereum is going to drop so much
more and that's exactly what happened
right so um not really sure what's going
to be the bottom of this chart could it
be here I think likely but I need I
think I need more time to uh reanalyze
and chart this uh this pair again so
another chart would be the Bitcoin
dominance and probably the most
difficult H chart to analyze um again we
I've been right about this chart for um
longer than a year around 2 years every
single move now the last move I was
wrong I was thinking that 61. 55% was
the top um I was hoping to see here you
know lower highs you can see here you
have your top then potential lower high
here Trend continuation but that go
broken exactly here so if you notice the
moment that we went Above This doted
white line then I knew you know my idea
is invalidated Bitcoin dominance can go
higher that's what we've been talking in
the last video so yeah my idea on the
Bitcoin dominance was wrong personally I
don't see the Bitcoin dominance going
much higher than this I think I don't
think we're going to go to 70% I think
that the that the top is very close to
be formed potentially when QE starts
or at least that's what it would make
more sense compared to previous cycles
and something very clear that I'm seeing
here is that if you go into the daily
time frame we can see this long this
long week getting formed and the top is
64% right 61% and all is telling is that
Bitcoin dominance is going to fill this
week so that means that in the short
term you know if the Bitcoin dominance
goes up and and Bitcoin either goes down
or
stabilizes or
it or consolidates then altcoins are
going to go down and that is what I'm
also thinking that the alins are going
to fill their weeks okay so now let's go
into some
altcoins we're going to go back to these
charts later on but if we go into the AL
market then we can
see that you know this is total three so
this represents pretty much all the all
the all the altcoin market with also the
the stable coin so you can see that we
have here a very long week now this long
week is not filling a previous one yes
it partially fill this one here but you
can see how the long week that we've
created today goes beyond it by Miles it
it goes beyond it for qual more creating
a new inbalance so yes this new week
needs to get filed this new week is
valid is likely going to get failed at
the same time as the Bitcoin dominance
week to the upside gets failed right now
you can start to see uh a few
similarities you know if we go for
example into the AL like to um you can
see also here he created a huge weak to
the downside now perhaps you are
thinking oh no I missed the deep I
should have bought at 250 I should have
bought at
240 I should have bought at I don't know
280 and I never see the price again well
I would say that um it's very likely
that this we gets failed that we see
again those prices 270 250 very likely
so so I would say that you know wait for
it and see what kind of setup it gives
you if you are you know just trading in
a spot for the long term uh I would say
that um it's very likely that you get
that opportunity again and if you go
into different alchs you're going to see
the same look at this Ena broke the
bullish structure there once he broke
below that Y Line the structure is
broken it created a new week to them
side that weak need to get failed
probably it'll go back to at least 52
cents okay that's around 15% drop from
here so um again it'll get filled at the
same time as the Bitcoin dominance week
gets filled moreal coins you have
dotcoin new week created that will get
filled expected to get filled at least
to 22 cents more than a 10% drop from
here around 12% drop we continue
xrp huge
week okay and I do think it's very
likely that it goes back down all the
way to at least
$2.05 very likely potentially could get
fill 100% of this week and all the weeks
we be mentioned in the previous altcoin
so um be open-minded don't panic in both
ways because some people are going to be
panicking thinking you know you know
it's over bull market is over I'm going
to sell all my spot packs even if
they're at a loss and I'm going to get
out so for those people I would
say careful with the idea and this is
not Financial advice but it's true that
when we get a liquidation Cascade like
this one and this one is the biggest one
in
history is usually marks bottoms usually
marks short shortterm bounces at least
back to your entry so um careful there
and then there is also going to be other
type of of of of people that are going
to be thinking you know that week wow
there is a lot of buying pressure um I
missed the Deep so I'm going to buy here
um I also think that that's wrong to
think like that because this week seems
to get filled so it's very likely that
you can buy at least you know 30 %
cheaper than this um but that's just my
guess so if we go now into the CME gaps
these are very interesting topic because
it's true that most of them get filled
and if you go back down and check what
happened previously you can see how most
of them get eventually filled sooner or
later now it could be a case like this
one here you can see for example this
one in May that one didn't get filed
until November of the next year right so
um they don't necessar need to get
filled straight away usually that's the
case so if you go for example into this
range here you can see a few gaps like
for example this one gets filled pretty
fast you also have this one here gets
gets filled pretty fast I also see
another one here for example
all right so usually these gaps tend to
get filled pretty fast and if you notice
here this weekend we created a new Gap
to the upside all the way to
102,000 which means that it'll very
likely get filled fast also since we are
in a in a range and this is part of the
range so yeah it it's like that we see a
reaction from the range lows taking us
back all the way to 102k
now if in the weekly time
frame we start to see you know loads of
weeks to the site and price not
progressing any further which is already
what it's happening in both Direction so
um even more to the downside as I said
at the start of the video um then you
got to be careful okay you got to be
careful and if you see a breakout below
this level with a candle body not with a
wig with a candle body and that sustains
for two candles or more so basically you
know you don't see a recovery of that
candle the next week the next candle so
if the next if the second candle
basically if one candle breaks below
this area here and the second candle
doesn't recover the area then it's very
likely that from the third candle
onwards it drops okay and it would drop
towards this CME gap which is matching
with the weekly
50ma okay and at that point you would
have another great buying opportunity so
um that's what I'm thinking at the
moment just be careful um with how you
play this because um it's a it's I know
it's a tough week but but the main idea
what I make this video is uh to inform
you about that you know bitco is at the
range lows it's a support right now no
need to panic at least for now and in
the case of ethereum and other Al coins
then you know these long
weeks they are not filling previous
weeks so they need to get filled so wait
be patient even if price does something
like this and it goes back all the way
to
3,000 then it will eventually go all the
way down here okay so careful with that
guys um that's pretty much everything I
wanted to say guys thank you so much for
watching and I'll see you soon